I've had a lot of questions both in game
and in the comment sections about some
of the basics around creating a build in
the division since patches 1.7 and 1.8
have been released to have had a huge
influx of new players either coming back
to the game or starting fresh after
moving away from other titles that
haven't really met expectations to be
fear the game doesn't really address a
lot of these questions and effect it can
actually point you in the wrong
direction in some cases and a lot of
other information online is either
outdated or more based around the
endgame and in Game Gear so I'm going to
attempt to run through the basics of
creating a build this is directed at
people new to the game and wanting to
give a bit of an understanding on what
you should be looking for and how to get
started on thrown together your first
build I'll try to keep this pretty
simple so there's likely to be a few
questions that come out of this let me
know in the comments and I'll do my best
to provide an answer if there's a lot I
may put together a part two to this
guide where I go into a little bit more
depth as I'm writing this were in the
patch 1.8 version of the game as all RPG
MMO looter shooters go a lot can change
over a few patches so make sure to add
any changes that come up into the
description or release a new version of
this video if things change too much
firstly I need to state there really
isn't a wrong way of creating a build
it's one of the things I love about
these types of games there's an
unlimited number of build variations as
I've shown in a previous video even with
a subpar and optimized build you can
still complete most content in the game
although I must admit you have a pretty
hard time in some activities so although
there is no wrong way of doing it there
is certainly some more efficient and
effective builds that will make your
life a lot easier when you get into some
of these in-game missions with this
video I'll attempt to show this I'll
also include a couple of very basic
builds at the end of the video to get
you started I'm going to go ahead and
assume that you've made it to level 30
and to world tier 5 the same principles
can be used in tier 1 to 4 but in all
honesty if you aren't there yet get to
world tier 5 this is where the game
really begins first step what do you
want to achieve with the build do you
want to be putting up maximum damage
with your guns do you like the idea of
having strong damage dealing skills
would you rather play as a more of a
support bill
within the team or maybe you'd rather
focus on sustainability because you'll
be playing solo most of the time
whatever way you want to go you'll need
to figure this out first you can speak
into multiple different things and this
will be fine for a lot of the easier
content in the game but later on you'll
find you won't be quite strong enough
for do enough damage to be able to make
it through some of the more difficult
content the game has changed over the
years in the direction to promote more
of a role based to play for example the
team consisting of a healer DPS build
skill build and a tank build will have
more success than a team full of solo
player builds this example is probably
oversimplifying it a little bit but
hopefully you get the idea
build synergy and team synergy is the
key so it doesn't miss Sara to start out
with picking your role but it's a good
practice to get into and don't worry
about being stuck in a certain role this
is why we have loadouts
you can save and chop and change between
builds depending on the activity and
what your team requires once you've
decided on the build or roll direction
you'd like to take you can now start
picking through the items you pick up to
find the best gear and weapons to
complement your build so if you are
after a skill power build you should
look out for gear that complements
electronics and skill haste and weapons
that have talents that will further
increase the damage or intensity of your
skills with a DPS build you want your
gear to help with increasing your
firearms and damage output with weapons
that further increase your damage as a
solo player you'll need to be conscious
of your health so stamina and health
replenishment talents are a must I'm not
going to go through every whip and
talent and gear piece that's available
but I'll run through some of the gear
pieces based on the three roles DPS
skill power solo shown on screen right
now are my recommendations as far as the
gear major and minor attributes go for
the purpose of this video I'm showing
gear more suited to the PvE
aspect of the game this is much easier
to understand and a much better place to
start when you don't have all the best
gear in the game in regards to the solo
and DPS builds the major and - stat
options are very similar the main stats
firearms stamina electronics are where
they will differ
set-pieces our gear that offer unique
bonuses based on the number of other
pieces you have equipped from the same
set for example the Nomad set if you
have two pieces of Nomad equipped you
gain 15% health on kill three pieces you
gain an additional constant heal and
with four pieces equipped you gain path
of the Nomad ability these bonuses
particularly when you look at the full
four-piece sets are quite powerful and
offer you the ability to really
specialize in a particular role there
are currently 14 different sets
available each with their own talents
and their own part to play examples of
these are Nomad solo play huge emphasis
on keeping you alive tactician skill
build focuses on max skill power and
getting your skills back quickly
strikers DPS more heads equals more
damage
classified pieces are the same as normal
set pieces but with highest stats and
the ability to grant even greater
bonuses with five and six piece perks
these can be identified by the file icon
located on the top right these can be
used with normal set items but in order
to unlock the five and six piece bonuses
you need all pieces to be classified so
if you had four normal set items and
added a fifth classified item to the
same set
you'll still only have the four piece
bonus unlocked classified items are
currently the most sought-after gear in
the game outside of global events only
the most difficult in-game activities
will award these pieces
gear mods are additional modifications
that you can add to your gear to further
personalize your build there are two
types of gear mods standard gear mods
which increases certain main stat
firearms stamina electronics and also
provide a bonus stat and performance
mods which gives you another bonus stat
your gear can have five standard gear
mods and four performance mods on your
build screen you can see what gear
pieces can take which mods based on
these slots at the bottom left for
standard mods and bottom right for
performance mods
exotic items are rare pieces of gear
that are most sought after much like the
classified gear they are the equivalent
of legendary or artifact items in other
games exotics are known for the unique
exclusive talents they have some are
good some are not
regardless hold on to them quite often
these items are reviewed and an upcoming
patch can see these go from trashed here
to one of the most sought-after items in
the game
regardless of whether you're running a
skill build or a DPS build skills have a
large part to play like everything else
with the covered up until now you need
to pick skills that compliment your
build damage-dealing skills won't do
anything for you if you aren't running
high enough skill power so a DPS or
solar build should focus more on skills
like the pulse and first aid that will
help the damage and survivability skill
power builds this is where you shine you
can run things like support station and
smart cover if you'd like to support the
team or you can push out some extra
damage using skills like seeker Minds
sticky bomb or turret talents add small
bonuses that can really make or break
certain situations some are quite
specific with what will they give and
can really make a difference depending
on what you're running as a rough guide
some of the more commonly used talents
are critical save combat medic strike
back precision on the move and one is
none
have you found the perfect weapon but it
has a talent that just doesn't work for
you or maybe you have a good nomad piece
that dropped with electronics but you
really needed firearms no problem this
is where the recalibration station comes
in all weapons and gear can have a
single perk or attribute re rolled into
something different you can do this as
many times as you want the gear it cost
standard credits and weapons it cost
Phoenix credits and weapon kits the only
exception is the classified gear this
can have two perks re-rolled
every item excluding mods has a gear
score the gear score is an indication of
how optimized the gear piece or weapon
is your character is then given a gear
score based on the average of all of
your weapons and gear this isn't an
indication of the type of gear or weapon
and has nothing to do with the talents
for example if I had two lightweight M
force and one had damage rating of 18
point 4 K and the other had a rating of
18 point 2 K the one with a higher
damage would have a higher gear score
but does that make it a bit of weapon if
the 18 point 2 K has better talents this
is still a better gun to use and the
same goes for gear a new player can be
forgiven for thinking that the higher
the gear score the bit of the item is
this isn't necessarily untrue but if the
talents are worse and you end up
breaking set bonuses stick with the low
gear score items I've seen a number of
285 plus gear score builds that are much
less effective than some 260 gear score
builds repeating myself again it's all
about synergy between the weapons
talents and gear pieces at almost two
years old I'm not sure how useful this
video will be but I love this game and
if I can help keep the player base
growing I'm more than happy to keep
producing content like this new players
let me know if I can provide more
clarity and I'll do my best either
through the comments section or future
videos day 1 or longtime players of the
game let me know if missed anything
vital as I said earlier this is just
meant to be a simplified version of how
to create a build there is a huge number
of options that I haven't discussed here
but on requests I'll be happy to go into
more detail on screen should be some
very basic DPS skill and solo builds
that can be used as a starting point
take a screenshot but they should be
taken as just that a starting point
modify and adapt these to your style of
play anyway as always thank you very
much for watching and see you in the
next video Cheers
[Music]